one of the main highlights today was
that we secured the council's general
approach on the European travel and
information authorization system the
agreement we have reached today will
pave the way for further discussions
with the European Parliament and
hopefully the proposal can be adopted by
the end of this year as called for by
the European Council we also had a
debate on the Schengen information
system on ways to amend and improve and
possibly also optimize the effectiveness
of the system over lunch ministers
discussed counterterrorism they had a
discussion on the next steps on the
radicalization awareness network network
the ran and they were also briefed by
the EU counterterrorism coordinator as
well as the Maltese chairperson of the
counter terrorism group I'm pleased that
the member states have agreed their
position on ATS this is an initiative
that will strengthen our security and
the management of our borders the
currency today also committed to push
the work forward on interoperability for
security and border management
cooperation with key third countries on
all these issues is crucial and I look
forward to a fruitful discussion at the
EU us ministerial meeting that will take
place in Malta next week today we also
discussed the reform of the common
European Asylum system we need a crisis
a resistance system which is both
effective and fair now's the moment to
build on our achievements so far and
continue moving forward both on
migration and security issues